okay I told you last week that a really
great supporter of the program
Jennifer karein sponsored for free
one-year memberships the theme was
progressive patriotism you had to write
in a short letter poem or story that is
a version of patriotic progressivism not
allowing the right and their harebrained
definition of patriotism to win and I
have four winners to announce to you
today and I will read to you their great
writings the first winner of a free
membership courtesy of Jennifer karein
is scott rogers who wrote a very very
nice poem where he said they circumvent
my circumstance selling tombs for cash
in hand indoctrinate with a salesman's
glance selling songs on deaf ears land
my sense of faith will permeate
entrenched in such a brittle stare
broadly broken but I'll embrace I'll
raise my voice as is my choice corporate
coke can't buy my stake that's really
good and Scott Rogers has now won
himself a free year membership as a
result of that pat doing snapping is
that what you do at a poetry slam okay
yeah uh no I don't really know much
about slam culture myself okay the next
winner is Mohammed Al Jalal who wrote in
with a very interesting letter or a poem
I don't I guess this is kind of a poem
for this nation I owe a debt a debt
awaiting repayment for this nation
I escaped oppression and aggression for
freedom I came to this nation dreaded by
the past and in desperate need of
affection and fondness to later break
out in tears when the country opened its
doors to host a stranger for it was my
destiny to be a part of this nation and
that wall in between collapsed under the
power of perseverance and determination
freedom liberty equality these are the
qualities that define us Americans
winner I love it very good I mean I'm
still looking for affection and fondness
and I've lived in this country my whole
life
right and Mohammed has found it already
our next winner of a free David Pakman
show membership courtesy of Jennifer
crane is Scott Riordan Scott Reardon
wrote a progressive Patriot demands
these things from their elected
officials stop the wars single-payer
health care for all living minimum wage
Free State University for all
infrastructure we build America get
money out of politics publicly funded
elections improve public schools embrace
education tax reform to pay for it
reduce national debt transition away
from fossil fuels protect our
environment common-sense gun legislation
tougher banking regulations immigration
reform these are basic values that
transcend any political party
these are patriotic values that a
majority of Americans can agree with we
the people need to skillfully articulate
our values to those who represent us
Scott Reardon you are a progressive
Patriot and you have won a free one-year
membership and lastly the fourth of four
winners courtesy of Jennifer Cain's
membership donation is someone whose
last name I am withholding named
Brittney who wrote in David my story is
not as simple or easy one to recount
I've suffered through childhood sexual
abuse mental illness chronic physical
illness and disability today July 7th is
my 29th birthday I consider myself a
progressive and I have great pride in my
country even though there are things I
don't like about it getting a solid hold
on my beliefs has been a rough road one
that I am still on and will likely be on
for years to come now though I know I
want to help people I want what's best
for all not just for me in mind
this road I'm on now lets me know what
it truly means to be a progressive and
is allowing me to figure out how I will
translate that into this country and the
world I want to become an advocate for
many things as a young adult I have
unusual personal experience and quite a
few things private insurance applying
for disability Social Security Medicare
Medicaid mental health and its treatment
to name a few I want to help others so
their roads are less bumpy they're been
mine I want to change the world
congratulations Brittany you also now
have a free one-year membership
membership really congratulations to all
Pat big thanks to Jenna
for karein this was a good giveaway I
like this one I think we got a lot out
of this one
sure in contrast to the right-wing blind
patriotism of just supporting your
country no matter what I think we see
examples here of though we're not
perfect we are patriots by wanting to
change the things that are bad about
them I agree with you so Jennifer thank
you for doing this we will feel if
you're one of the four winners feel free
to reach out to us and we'll set up your
membership if not you'll hear from us in
the next 24 to 48 hours